احنا طول عمرنا بنسمع من الناس عباره 360
درجه اللي بيربطوها على طول انه بالتغيير
الكلي يعني مثلا بنشوف شخص متغير نقول
تغير 360 درجه او يعني معاملته مقلوبه 360
درجه لكن هذه الجمله هي غلط شائع بين
الناس فالتغير الجدري بيكون 180 درجه من
اقصى اليمين لاقصى اليسار لكن التغير 360
درجه لا هذا ببساطه لف لفته كامله ورجع
لنقطه البدايه يعني تماما عكس المقصود
فيها وان الناس بتغلط بين يعني 180 درجه
و300 درجه هذا شيء وانه وزيره تغلط غلطه
مثل هذه فهذا شيء ثاني يعني مشكله بتصير
وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه غلطت هذه الغلطه
وفي تصريح وجهه لروسيا وقالتها يعني وقالت
لها انه كذا اللي ضمان امن اوكرانيا بنصحك
يا روسيا تغير سياستك 360 درجه
المسكينه امين يعني طاحت ومع مين علقت
يعني في هذا الموضوع يعني تغلط الغلطه هذه
يعني
وبعدين المسؤولين الروس طبعا انتهزها فرصه
فنزلوا في الوزير الالمانيه اتهامات
بالجهل قصف جبهات من كل الجوانب المتحدثه
طبعا باسم الخارجيه مريضه يعني معروفه هذه
جلسه مستنيه العمله اي احد استعارت نفس
تركيبه جمله تصريح الوزير الالمانيه
الوزير الالمانيه قالت لضمان امن اوكرانيا
لازم روسيا تغير سياستها زخرفه ردت عليها
وقالت لها لضمان امن المانيا يروح اتعلم
يدرس واحد على الاقل اما نائب رئيس مجلس
الامن الروسي
فرد عليها عبر تغريده على تويتر قال فيها
ان يديرها هؤلاء الجهله اوروبا وطلب من
الوزيره انه او انه طلب الوزيره انه موسكو
تتغير 360 درجه يعني تفضل مثل ما هي
ووصفها بالخبيره الهندسيه كنوع من انواع
الاستهزاء وقال انهم متمسكين بمواقفهم
طبعا يعني
بياخذوا دروس كده في فنون فنون الرد
وصراحه هذه 360 جاطعهم على طبق من ذهب
بصراحه يعني صعب كان ما يرده يعني